you have all these voices that are
telling you you're [__] up and this is
going to be hard but for some reason you
put so much practice into you that you
can ignore every one of them that are
telling you you're not going to [__]
make it and still be able to [__]
make it because you have put the
practice in that you know this is the
process it's such a daunting task that
all the voices are saying no but you
still have the conviction that I know I
can do this and that's what it took for
me to get here when you put that
practice in every day you lay some up I
don't mean run it's just a metaphor for
life when you lace them [__] up
every day pretty soon you win you have
the courage and the heart and the
dedication and the mindset about
everybody can go [__] themselves I know
what I know I've listened to myself
enough to know I know what I know none
of you can hear what I'm hearing and
that's what people don't do enough of
they don't listen to their Journey they
listen to everybody else's [__] you're
not looking at the truth in front of you
the truth in front of you is that sucks
This Is What It Takes creating another
voice and sometimes going at it alone